hallo und herzlich willkommen zum
zweiten Versuch das Starship zu launchen
freut mich sehr wenn ihr heute mit dabei
seid happy 420 heute ist der 20 April
und ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher wie
sehr Elon Musk heute unbedingt haben
wollte diesen Launch obwohl es
vielleicht gar nicht so sinnvoll ist
einfach nur wegen des jokes an 420 zu
starten das Wetter ist so semi das wäre
Montag besser gewesen da gucken wir
gleich noch mal genauer drauf wie weit
das Team inzwischen daran gearbeitet hat
das gefrorene Ventil zu beheben das
wissen wir einfach nicht was man sowas
Insider Kreisen hört ist wohl einiges
tatsächlich gerade so dabei
das
dass das Team hat dran gearbeitet hat
und anscheinend wollen die heute komme
was wolle starten wie sehr das von ihnen
Maske von oben kamen allein wegen des
Jobs das heute vor 20 ist unklar
allerdings auf jeden Fall soll es heute
losgehen haben wir so ein bisschen
gehört ich bin schon mal gespannt was
denkt werden wir heute starten werden
wir heute nicht starten schreibt es in
den Chat ich bin doch schon mal sehr
gespannt wir lesen alle eure Kommentare
ich kann nicht auf jeden einzelnen
Kommentar eingehen allerdings haben wir
ganz ganz tolle Mods die behind the
scenes die besten Fragen raussuchen so
dass ich dann auch darauf eingehen kann
also schreibt gerne Fragen rein packt
alles in den Chat ich möchte ganz gerne
mit Euch hier drüber quatschen was ihr
heute
großartiges historisches passiert denn
das Starship könnte die Raumfahrt
revolutionieren und das ist kein kleines
Wort es ist die leistungsstärkste Rakete
die hier gebaut wurde wenn sie denn und
diejenigen Orbit kommen wenn sie dann in
den Orbit kommt das ist die größte
Rakete die hier gebaut wurde und die
schwerste Rakete die je gebaut wurde
wenn Sie heute abhebt ist es auch
einfach das schwerste Objekt und das
größte Objekt das je vom Boden abgehoben
ist
es könnte das lauteste Ding werden was
wir jemals recordet haben weil es ein
unglaublich lautes Geräusch geben würde
ich werde auf jeden Fall also wenn wir
dann gleich starten und die 33 Rap der
Triebwerke gezündet werden wenn ich auf
jeden Fall ruhig sein damit wir uns das
ganze anhören können wir werden auch
gleich die ganze Zeit den SpaceX
Livestream zeigen der soll in 12 Minuten
online gehen vorher werde ich euch
gleich noch so ein bisschen erzählen was
heute alles losgeht und was heute was
wir heute erwarten können bis dahin
gucke ich noch mal ganz kurz in den Chat
geht es euch gut was geht so
das Wetter sieht dort nämlich aus genau
das ist es auch man hat nicht so gute
Sichtverhältnisse und weiter oben könnte
auch der Wind zu schaffen machen das
meinte ich mit es sieht nicht so optimal
aus lass uns da gerne mal abwarten wie
es weiter läuft space exakt selber wir
beobachten das Wetter weiterhin das
heißt es noch kein 100%iges Ghost kann
gut sein dass wir den Start heute leider
diesmal dann wegen des Wetters wieder
absagen müssen wieder verschieben müssen
das nächste Startfenster wäre dann
morgen ab 14 Uhr auch da würden wir dann
wieder für euch Livestream also
vielleicht sehen wir uns morgen wieder
ich hoffe aber natürlich dass es heute
soweit ist und dass wir heute diese
Rakete starten sehen allerdings direkt
mal expection Management wie
wahrscheinlich ist es heute dass wir ein
kompletten Erfolg sehen
je nachdem wie man Erfolg definiert wenn
man erwartet dass das SpaceX das
Starship quasi in den Orbit fliegt und
wieder landet genauso wie das
theoretisch geplant ist dann sind die
Chancen extrem gering also wirklich mega
gering ich glaube es wird vorher
irgendwo explodieren aber selbst das
wäre je nachdem wie weit das kommt noch
ein großer großer Erfolg wenn wir heute
maxq schaffen also den Bereich wo das
Starship die meiste Kraft erfährt wenn
es das überlebt dann haben wir erstmal
eine Rakete die funktioniert dann wissen
wir dass die Produktionstechniken
funktionieren und dann kann man von da
aus weitermachen das ist ungefähr 1
Minute nach Start soll aktuell 15,28
sein das wäre dann 15 und 29 wenn die
Rakete das überlebt haben wir erstmal
einen großen Erfolg wenn sie danach
explodiert überhaupt kein Problem ich
persönlich würde tatsächlich erwarten
dass sie sogar schon vorher explodiert
aber schreibt mir gerne mal in die
Kommentare was ihr erwartet schreibt es
in den Chat rein glaubt ihr wir werden
heute gar nicht starten wird der
Betankung quasi wird wieder abgebrochen
wegen des Wetters ist wieder irgendein
Ventil kaputt oder eingefroren werden
wir vorm exq explodieren wird alles
hundertprozentig genauso klappen wie es
geplant ist würde mich auch
interessieren wenn ihr das glaubt
schreibt es gerne in den Chat rein
also was erwartet uns heute erstmal
können wir gleich schon mal sagen dass
Starship wenn es denn startet würde
unglaublich viele Weltrekorde brechen
und unglaublich vieles neues
revolutionieren und viele Leute in der
Branche sprechen schon von before
Starship und after Starship also das
wirklich jetzt ein monumentales Ding
erreicht ist wenn wir diesen Punkt
überschritten haben wird es nur noch ein
nach dem Starship geben denn das größte
Ding wird wahrscheinlich sein dass die
Kosten reduziert werden wenn das heute
funktioniert wird SpaceX die Kosten um
ins Weltall und in den Orbit zu kommen
unglaublich krasse senken ich habe mir
mal ein paar Zahlen rausgesucht ihr
wisst ja vielleicht das SLS dazu haben
wir auch ein paar Livestreams gemacht
ist letztes Jahr zum ersten Mal
gestartet das kostet die NASA so
roundabout 2,2 Milliarden Dollar pro
Start
SpaceX möchte wenn das Starship dann
einmal regelmäßig gebaut wird und vor
allem komplett wiederverwendbar ist für
gerade mal 10 Millionen Dollar pro Start
starten können das ist weniger als ein
200er der Kosten für das SLS und dabei
kann das Starship mehr transportieren
und ist sofort wiederverwendbar also es
soll quasi wieder aufgefangen werden und
danach wenigen Stunden schon wieder
fliegen können was revolutionär ist was
unglaublich krass ist wenn das
funktioniert dann werden wir heute
miterleben wie die Raumfahrt
revolutioniert wird wie gesagt ich
glaube nicht dass es alles
hundertprozentig funktioniert allerdings
können wir schon ein bisschen damit
rechnen dass wir was sehen werden denn
SpaceX hat viel getestet ist viel
gescheitert das war auch Teil des Plans
das SpaceX Philosophie ist ja schnell
was ausprobieren schnell scheitern und
dann daraus lernen wir haben viele
Explosionen gesehen in den letzten zwei
Jahren und wir haben viel mitbekommen
was alles
was alles gemacht wurde deswegen möchte
ich mir damals eine kleine
Zusammenfassung angesehen wir haben so
ein Video gefunden wo die Starship
Prototypen gezeigt werden vom
allerersten Prototypen bis dann zu sn15
wo dann der die Start und die Landung
wieder funktioniert wenn wir da mal kurz
reinschauen könnten in der Regie dann
kann ich dazu ein bisschen was erzählen
genau perfekt hier haben wir den Star
Hopper das war schon 2019 quasi
Ewigkeiten her allerdings in
raumfahrtszeiten gar nicht so lange her
wenn man mal überlegt wie lange das SLS
also das Space Launch System von der
NASA schon in development ist das ist
glaube seit 2010 oder seit 2011 im
aktiven development staropper ist 2019
das erste Mal geflogen also die haben
viel viel später gestartet und dafür
dass Tasche wenn es dann heute startet
gerade mal 5 Monate nach dem SMS dann
den Orbit erreicht muss man sagen
Starship ist einfach schon deutlich
deutlich schneller als die NASA und die
private Raumfahrt revolutionierte gerade
einiges also das ist der Hopper er
springt nach oben wenige hundert Meter
und landet dann wieder ein bisschen
weiter links auf dem Pad und tatsächlich
dieser erste Test hatte schon direkt
funktioniert
damals noch sehr viel kleiner dass da
schon bisher inzwischen deutlich größer
geworden allerdings sehen wir hier
wunderschön das müssen so ungefähr wird
es wahrscheinlich gleich auch wir werden
sehr viele Wolken sehen dass allerdings
hier Staub was wir gleich sehen werden
ist das flüssige Methan dass dann das
was wir jetzt gerade sind diese weiße
Wolke was dann sofort anfängt zu kochen
wenn es mit der Atmosphäre in Verbindung
kommt hier sehen wir die große Spraydose
ich finde sie wirklich aus wie eine
fliegende lustige so eine Graffiti Spray
Dose die umher fliegt vor allem an den
Knopf da oben drauf
auch das die ersten Tests noch
allerdings da schon konnte man sehen in
welche Richtung es geht das Starship
soll ist insgesamt jetzt gerade wie es
auf dem Patch steht 120 Meter hoch soll
aber bald sogar 130 Meter hoch werden
ist damit das größte und höchste Berg
die höchste Rakete die jemals gebaut
wurde das Starship selber das ship ist
50 m hoch der Booster ist 69 m hoch Höhe
wahrscheinlich auch kein Zufall dass ihr
eine Master bestimmt noch mal ein
bisschen paar Meter abgesagt hat nur
damit 69 sind der Booster wird auch
super heavy genannt beides hat 9 m
Durchmesser das müsst ihr euch erstmal
vorstellen 9 Meter das ist größer als
der Raum in dem ich gerade sitze das ist
wahrscheinlich auch größer als der Raum
in dem ihr gerade sitzt und das ist der
Durchmesser von diesem Raumschiff die
Höhe ist noch mal viel viel höher 120 m
sind 40 Stockwerke das ist also wirklich
ein Hochhaus das aktuell steht dass da
gebaut wurde das super super schwer ist
5000 Tonnen das dann gleich einfach weg
fliegen wird
es ist wirklich krass man kann gar nicht
sich vorstellen was das hier gerade für
Dimensionen sind dieser sich durch die
Lüfte bewegen allein im Starship gibt's
1200 Tonnen Treibstoff im Booster 3.400
Tonnen Treibstoff von 5000 Tonnen
Gesamtgewicht man sieht also das meiste
am Starship sind tatsächlich das meiste
Gewicht ist tatsächlich dass der
Treibstoff selber
und ich habe es vorhin schon gesagt es
würde dann gleich wenn es auch nur ein
Meter abhebt das größte und schwerste
Objekt sein dass jemals von der Erde
abgehoben ist die bisher schwerste
Rakete war die N1 mit 2750 Tonnen die
hat es allerdings nie in den Orbit
geschafft
so hier sehen wir das sn8
das war der erste Versuch 2020
der erste landesversuch genau das ist
sehr sehr spannend denn wir sehen jetzt
gleich den belly Flop der wird auch für
uns heute relevant sein da sieht man
schon die beiden fins oben zwei unten
zwei und die sind dafür da wenn das
Tasche gleich wieder in die Atmosphäre
Eintritt also fällt was gleich passieren
wird jetzt gegen ihre jetzt gehen gleich
die Engines aus die Triebwerke gehen
gleich aus dann fällt das Tasche wieder
Richtung Erde und wird dann mit dem
Bauch zuerst fallen um mehr Reibung zu
erzeugen und zwar langsamer zu fallen
und diese beiden diese vier fins werden
das ganze steuern da ist unglaubliche
Kraft die auf diesem mechanischen fins
liegt die kann ja auch noch gesteuert
werden wenn diese Mechanik irgendwie
fehlt wird das Flasche sofort in alle
Teile zerrissen werden
allerdings kann man hier gleich ganz gut
sehen funktioniert hat da in diesem Test
funktioniert und dass da schon wird
jetzt gleich in eine in ein baliflock
gehen also quasi wie ein
Fallschirmspringer in diese Position
gehen wo man Arme und Beine von sich
Wegstrecken so einer stabilen
bauchposition ist und jetzt hier sehen
wir die fins wie Sie anfangen zu
justieren dass Starship geht mit dem
Bauch nach vorne da wird dann auch der
Hitzeschild drauf sein um das um die
Hitze abzulenken aus Keramik und jetzt
fällt das Starship einfach frei mit dem
Bauch nach vorne Richtung Erde und wird
dadurch halt langsamer als es fallen
würde wenn es wie eine Rakete die
startet nach oben startet und jetzt
gleich kommt das Flip Manöver das ist
wirklich schwierig das ist wirklich
krass das Taschen muss kurz vorher macht
es wieder die Triebwerke an Flip drüber
und steht sehr stellt sich dann wieder
gerade auf um dann senkrecht zu landen
was unglaublich ist krasse Idee und sehr
sehr interessant wie man darauf kommt
großes Risiko auch aber man kann hier
sehen die Idee funktioniert Flip vom vom
belly Flop rüber in die Senkrechte und
dann genau landing burn gibt es Schub
damit es ganz sanft aufsetzt hier selbst
ist leider nicht sanft auf und es macht
bum das war der erste Land versuch dann
kam 2021 der zweite Lehrling versuche
ich kann schon mal Spoilern auch der
wird leider leider nicht ganz so perfekt
ausgehen es dauert noch ein bisschen
aber man sieht SpaceX macht sehr sehr
schnell neue starships sie können die
sehr sehr schnell bauen die bauen auch
jetzt gerade schon in Florida erste
Fabrik wo sie dann noch mehr starships
bauen können damit davon einfach sehr
viele gebaut werden alles mit dem Ziel
die Kosten für die Raumfahrt zu
reduzieren das ein Kilogramm denen ins
Orbit in den Orbit zu bringen geringer
wird das ist das große Ziel von SpaceX
um am Ende des Tages zum Mars zu kommen
was ja Elon Musk möchte wir möchten ähm
er möchte den Mars
besiedeln und wenn er das wenn er das
schaffen will dafür muss halt die Kosten
pro 1 kg oder pro Tonne deutlich
reduziert werden ich hatte gerade schon
gesagt dass SLS würde dann um 1.200 ähm
Unterboden werden selbst die Felge
hinein kostet aktuell 67 Millionen
Dollar pro Start die wollen mit den
Starship auf 10 Millionen Dollar pro
Stunde kommen also das ist lachhaft
wenig in der Raumfahrt Industrie was sie
da gerade versuchen und vielleicht sogar
bald hinbekommen werden wenn es denn
heute funktioniert
genau hier sehen wir wieder den belly
Flop den werden wir theoretisch heute
auch sehen wahrscheinlich nicht so toll
hoch auflösend weil das ganz woanders
wieder landen wird und in meinen Augen
werden wir sowieso nicht sehen weil sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist dass das dass wir
sowas heute kommen werden und auch hier
Mum Rapid an scheduley ähm
also sehr sehr schnelle sehr sehr
schnelles abbauen durch Explosion genau
SN 10 im März 2021 wurde es dann wieder
versucht also auch hier es geht
erstaunlich schnell weiter
habt ihr Fragen schreibt sie gerne in
den Chat wir lesen alle eure Fragen
dieses sammelt sich hier alles gerade
schon bei uns danke an die Mods die das
hier alles gerade sammeln schreibt sie
gerne in den Chat wir lesen alles ich
komme gleich dazu
420 sagt sorry aber das ist eine
ziemlich doofe Unterstellung sollte es
heute starten dann nicht wegen dem Joke
das ist einfach Quatsch sinnlose
Spekulation ja kann sein war einfach ich
kenne ja elemaske macht schon viel für
einen Joke aber ja natürlich also die
haben jetzt nicht extra auf den April
hing gearbeitet und das ganze länger
laufen lassen die versuchen schon sehr
dieses Starship ready zu bekommen kann
mir auch schon vorstellen wenn es heute
nicht ganz optimal ist ein kleines
Risiko ist dass irgendwas gesagt hey
komm Leute wenn wir es heute irgendwie
hinbekommen wäre das Mega und dann
machen auch alle Mitarbeiter da
irgendwie mit weil sie Spaß daran haben
hier wieder der Flip das Flip Manöver
vom belly Flop und dann in die
Senkrechte zu gehen das würden wir heute
nicht sehen heute wenn das Starship
selber das Schiff so weit kommt dass es
nördlich von Hawaii in den Pazifik fällt
dann tatsächlich einfach mit dem Bauch
nach vorne ins Wasser einfach auf
hier der landen die Landung sieht jetzt
erstmal sauber aus
wir setzen auf allerdings war diese
Landung damals härter als erwartet und
das ganze ist dann später explodiert das
können wir jetzt hier leider nicht sehen
und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht was
das wo ist das erste mal funktioniert
hat
wie stehen die Chancen für eine
ungeplante rasante Demontage
ach genau sn15 war das was funktioniert
hat
fünfter mai 2021 hier sehen wir jetzt
gleich den ersten sauberen die erste
saubere Landung von Starship
wir stehen die Chance für eine
ungeplante rasante Demontage sehr hoch
würde ich persönlich sagen aber das
heißt nicht dass das heute dann ein
Fehler ist also wenn wir heute in
Explosion sehen was wir in meinen Augen
wahrscheinlich sehen werden irgendwo
zumindest dann heißt das nicht dass
heute nicht irgendwas trotzdem
erfolgreich ist
greenshotwell also die CEO von SpaceX
sagt selber dass es wenn das nicht das
Launchpad zerstört ist alles schon mal
gut alles schon erfolgreich also wenn
das da schrieb mit dem Booster zusammen
ein paar Meter weg kommt und dann da
explodiert auch überhaupt kein Problem
dann ist schon mal alles erfolgreichen
wir würden viel viel gelernt haben ich
persönlich kann mir gut vorstellen dass
es irgendwo zwischen dem Start und maxq
dann sich auseinanderreißen wird weil
die Kräfte einfach zu groß sind also
irgendwann in den ersten 60 Sekunden des
Starts ich drücke aber natürlich den
Daumen dass wir heute eine perfekte im
perfekte Landung und alles mögliche
sehen was genau wir gleich zu erwarten
haben erzähle ich gleich noch mal
erstmal wollen sie noch die Landung
angucken
von sn15
da gab es ein paar Übertragungsprobleme
das sind die drei rapta Triebwerke
Raptor 2 Triebwerke die haben wir auch
in dem aktuellen Starship wie es auf dem
Booster gerade drauf steht
und jetzt sehen wir hier den belly Flop
das ist wirklich ziemlich cool
dargestellt dass die Kamera auch an
dieser an dieser Finnen dran an dieser
Finne dran und man kann quasi wie die
ganze Zeit nach justiert wird wie der
Computer die ganze Zeit justiert und
beobachtet wie sich das darsche quasi
bewegt wie es fällt um es stabil zu
halten wie das tatsächlich halt auch
Fallschirmspringer machen
und wir haben eine Landung
genau das war SN 15 nur das Starship
heute wird noch ein Booster da drunter
liegen
und deutlich deutlich mehr Push geben
deutlich mehr Delta wie geben also
Veränderungen in Geschwindigkeit denn
heute wollen wir in den Orbit kommen
oder in ein quasi Orbit das Starship
soll heute so einmal fast komplett um
den Erdball herumfliegen und theoretisch
dann wieder Landem
aber lasst uns doch mal weiter vorne
starten es gibt so eine coole Grafik die
man dazu einblenden kann
und zwar kann man da ganz gut sehen wie
das Starship startet dann einmal um den
Erdball fliegt und dann wieder landen
soll
und genau da haben wir das Starship da
können wir einmal sehen es wird das sind
die Minuten Anzahlen hier die einzelnen
Punkte nach dem Start und nach ungefähr
70 Minuten wird es dann wieder über
nördlich von Hawaii soll das Starship
dann wieder irgendwo landen der Booster
allerdings direkt am Anfang schon noch
im Golf von Mexiko soll wieder
zurückfliegen und wird dann auch
senkrecht
quasi wieder landen über das Wasser
kommen und dann soll es quasi simuliert
werden dass es von diesen Greifarmen
gefangen wird es gibt ja diesen Laun von
dem auch gestartet wird und der hat so
Greif Arme was ein krasses Konzept ist
und dann wird der quasi so ankommen und
von diesen Greifarm gepackt und wird
dann festgehalten und kann dann
theoretisch auch wieder neu aufgebaut
werden
allerdings wird das heute nicht probiert
der launchtower wird da quasi nicht
angegriffen genau da sehen wir die und
dann sehen wir auch die Greifarme und
das ganze wird heute nicht passieren
denn der Booster wird quasi über dem
Wasser einfach so landen oder kurz über
dem Wasser schweben wird kurz simulieren
gegriffen zu werden und soll dann aber
im Wasser versenkt werden SpaceX möchte
auch nicht bergen das möchte einfach
dass das Ganze im Meer versinkt das
Starship selber allerdings fliegt einmal
um den Erdball herum und soll dann
nördlich von Hawaii landen und wir sehen
hier diesen belly flott bei der Nummer 7
da kommt ganz ganz viel Energie auf den
Hitzeschild und wird davon absorbiert
und dann soll das ganze nicht vertikal
wieder im Wasser landen sondern einfach
mit dem Bauch nach vorne aufs Wasser auf
platzen und auch da im Meer versinken
also nicht soll heute wieder verwendet
werden der Test wenn er optimal und
perfekt läuft hat trotzdem zwei Dinge im
Ozean bzw Pazifik versenkt
genau also wir können heute erwarten
dass wir erst
starten nach zwei Minuten werden sich
die beiden Dinge Trennen der Booster die
70 Meter unten werden sich von dem
Starship für den 50 Metern oben trennen
das eine fliegt einmal um den Erdball
herum im Optimalfall und das andere
landet direkt wieder im Golf von Mexiko
genau hier sehen wir noch mal das
Starship komplett aus Edelstahl
tatsächlich eine sehr spannende
Designentscheidung denn ja jede Maske
selber gesagt das war eine der
wichtigsten Entscheidungen für das
Starship denn es wurde ja viel auch
kritisiert ich meine es Edelstahl ist
deutlich schwerer deutlich dichter als
andere Metalle hat aber auch z.B den
Vorteil dass es sowohl bei höheren als
auch bei niedrigeren Temperaturen
beständiger ist ähm und deswegen haben
sie sich dann für Edelstahl entschieden
und nicht für
Aluminium oder irgendwas mit Carbonfaser
sondern für Edelstahl auch hier noch mal
9 Meter Durchmesser man kann sich gar
nicht vorstellen wie riesig groß diese
Rakete ist tatsächlich könnte die
gesamte der Innenraum der ISS komplett
innerhalb der Lade
innerhalb des Laderaums von Starship
Platz finden also es ist sehr sehr viel
Platz da drin Kapazität 100 bis 150
Tonnen das ist auch unglaublich viel 150
Tonnen wiederverwendbar möchtest da als
Basics schaffen das heißt es werden 150
Tonnen payload in den Erdorbit befördert
und danach kann man sowohl den Booster
als auch das Starship wiederverwenden
wenn man beide nicht wieder verwendet
sind sogar 250 Tonnen payload möglich
das ist unglaublich viel und ähm auch
unglaublich günstig trotzdem noch im
Vergleich zum SMS also ich gehe mal
stark davon aus selbst wenn SpaceX das
Starship komplett verliert wenn Sie
immer noch deutlich günstiger sein als
ein Staat vom SLS z.B und das SRF
schafft weniger als 100 Tonnen zum
Vergleich also selbst wenn quasi nur der
geringste payload geschafft wird und
dass da schon wieder verwendet wird
schafft das Starship mehr laut als das
SLS der NASA und ich glaube da sieht man
auch schon so ein bisschen wohin hier
die Reise geht wir werden
in meinen Augen glaube ich eine
Revolution erleben
so der SpaceX Livestream ist gestartet
aktuell sehen wir nur ein Logo
allerdings soll es gleich dann wohl
losgehen heute starten wir offiziell
oder startet das öffnet sich der
Startfenster ab 15:28 Uhr das ist jetzt
in ja wir haben eingeblendet ne also in
43 Minuten
[Musik]
wenn wir Glück haben gar nicht das ist
noch das ist bald in 35 Minuten wenn wir
Glück haben sehen wir dann erstmal eine
große weiße Wolke bei 8 Sekunden vorher
werden die reptor Triebwerke gestartet
und Sie werden das flüssige Methan und
den Sauerstoff ausspucken das Launchpad
wird das ganze dann entzünden
und bei Sekunde 0 sollte dann die
Gravitation überwunden werden und das
Starship hat quasi mehr Schub nach oben
als es von der gerade von der Erde
angezogen wird und dann sollte das
Starship abheben bei T = 0
wenn wir dann eine Minute später sind
werden wir maxq hoffentlich erreichen
dass es wie gesagt der wichtigste Punkt
wenn die Rakete diesen Punkt aushält
dann haben wir den größten Erfolg den
wir uns eigentlich heute wünschen können
dann funktioniert das Starship und dann
können wir sehen dass das auf dem
richtigen Fahrt ist alles was danach
noch kommt sind nicht ganz so wichtige
Details hauptsache die ganzen Kräfte die
auf das Tasche wirken werden ausgehalten
bei noch ungefähr einer Minute bis zwei
dahinter ist dann Main Engine cut auf
Kot of und die Trennung also das der
Booster und das Starship trennen sich
der Booster fliegt zurück das Starship
wird weiter in den Orbit versuchen zu
kommen da gibt es dann noch mal sowohl
drei Raptor Triebwerke die für den fürs
Vakuum also fürs Weltall optimiert sind
drei für se Level also für die
Atmosphäre die werden dann erstmal Gas
geben um dem ja dem Starship genug
Geschwindigkeit zu geben und dann quasi
in orbit ähnlichen
Geschwindigkeit zu bekommen und im
Optimalfall landet das ganze dann wieder
nördlich von Hawaii mit einem
Bauchplatscher im Wasser
ganz kurz noch nie hat jemand versucht
etwas so großes an einem Stück zurück
zur Erde zu bringen die Kräfte die hier
auf der Straße wirken sind unglaublich
riesig groß jetzt sind wir noch mal das
Video hier ganz kurzer Hinweis an die
Regie beim letzten mal was er so dass da
Musik runterladen ich hoffe wir müssen
das jetzt mal sonst werden wir gleich
wieder Probleme bekommen mit dem
Algorithmus von Youtube da haben wir
gesagt bekommen hey hier äh da sind
irgendwelche Musik drin die wir
verwendet haben also es waren wirklich
nur 30 Sekunden die irgendwo im Stream
drin sind deswegen machen wir jetzt den
Space extra leise
so ich guck mal wieder an eure Fragen
und in den Chat rein ich hoffe euch geht
es gut ich hoffe ihr seid aufgeregt ich
bin wirklich sehr aufgeregt was beim
ersten Versuch schon heute noch umso
mehr weil ich heute das Gefühl habe dass
es noch umso eher passieren könnte in
meinen Augen kann es sehr gut sein dass
wir heute was historisches erleben diese
Rakete wenn sie dann funktioniert wird
vieles verändern wird die Raumfahrt in
gewisser Weise revolutionieren wie es
noch nie gesehen haben und es könnte so
eine Art Saturn 5 mondlandungsmoment
sein klar heute sind noch keine Menschen
an Bord sein reiner Testflug heute wir
erwarten wir quasi dass irgendwas
explodiert dennoch ist das Starship ein
so krasses Konzept und wenn es
funktioniert wird so viel verändern dass
wir ja tatsächlich im vorher und nachher
denken vor Starship und nach dem
Starship weil viele andere Raketen
ergeben einfach keinen Sinn mehr sobald
es da schon gibt so wir sind live SpaceX
ist live in 33 Minuten und 20 Sekunden
soll es losgehen die Betankung ist schon
lange lange dabei gerade fließt
flüssiges Methan und flüssiger
Sauerstoff in die Rakete und wir hören
mal in den Livestream sein was SpaceX
heute sozusagen hat
heißt
Engineering
[Musik]
das war der Grund warum es am Montag
nicht funktioniert hat ein Ventil ist
eingefroren und konnte dann bei der
tankum entweder konnte da nicht mehr
viel genug getankt werden oder die das
ist der Schlauch konnte da nicht mehr
losgelassen werden deswegen dann das
Kabel dranhängen würde bei dem Start
deswegen musste dann leider abgebrochen
werden wie Ingenieure haben es leider
nicht hinbekommen dass noch rechtzeitig
zu fixen und haben die letzten Tage dann
gearbeitet und anscheinend haben jetzt
das Go gegeben gesagt jetzt diesmal wird
es funktionieren also lass uns
weitermachen soweit ich das richtig
gesehen habe haben die ja noch bis
Sekunde 40 runtergegangen beim letzten
Mal das heißt alles andere hat dann
gesagt ich mag eigentlich nur noch an
diesem einen Ventil und wenn wir etwas
Glück haben dann wird es heute
auch nicht mehr in den Ventil legen und
wir starten heute
another go als Manning of you
das ist nicht nur das größte Video von
SpaceX sondern die größte Rakete aller
Zeiten mit 120 Metern und auch die
schwerste Rakete aller Zeiten 5000
Tonnen
genau 150 Tonnen usable 250 Tonnen nicht
real das ist auch sehr sehr sehr sehr
krass wenn das funktioniert
genau also heute ist ein Test wir wollen
heute ganz viele Daten sammeln wenn
irgendwas schief geht ist das auch
erstmal gut weil wir was lernen es geht
nicht darum irgendwas irgendwo
hinzubringen das sind keine Menschen
drin das wahrscheinlich nicht mal paylo
drin das ganze wurde wieder zugewandelt
die war also im Zweifel ist da nichts
drin und wir wollen heute einfach nur
gucken was passiert was mit der erste
integrierte Test und ähm deswegen alles
was passiert ist theoretisch erstmal gut
klar wenn es jetzt auf dem Launchpad
explodiert das wäre schon sehr schlimm
und würde wahrscheinlich alles im Monate
zurückwerfen vor allem wenn es das
Launchpad beschädigt aber wenn wir davon
erst mal wegkommen also nach dem ersten
10 20 Sekunden kann man eigentlich schon
sagen voller Erfolg egal was dann das
passiert selbst die Rakete dann
auseinander reist Alexander Müller hat
auch im Chat gefragt wo ich auch gerne
Fragen stellen könnt warum wird dieser
Staat wenn das klappt eine Revolution
sein das haben die beiden ja gerade auch
schon so ein bisschen erklärt weil es
die Kosten hoffentlich revolutionieren
wird also nochmal um ein Faktor 10 und
noch mehr wahrscheinlich sogar
reduzieren könnte ein Start für 10
Millionen Dollar mit 150 Tonnen payload
ist
unvorstellbar eigentlich in der
Raumfahrtindustrie wie gesagt das SLS
kostet 2,2 Milliarden also mehr als mehr
als 200-fache davon und kann weniger in
den Orbit bringen gut dass SLS ist
vielleicht auch ein schlechtes Beispiel
trotzdem wenn das Starship so
funktioniert wie SpaceX sich das
vorstellt wird der werden die Kosten pro
Kilogramm in um etwas zu bekommen
drastisch reduziert unglaublich krass
reduziert und das wird ermöglichen dass
wir zum Mond kommen die Nase hat für
Artemis 32
unter Vertrag genommen und diese das
Starship soll dann Menschen um den Mond
bringen und dann später auch auf dem
Mond wieder landen damit soll die erste
Frau die erste Person of color auf den
Mond kommen das wird alles noch dieses
Jahr 10 passieren es werden mehr private
Flüge möglich sein zum Beispiel die hier
die dir Moon Crew wird zum Beispiel auch
ein Youtuber dabei ist Tim dort der erst
der wird dann einmal zum Mond fliegen
würde nicht drauf landen einmal drum
rumfliegen was auch mit dem Star schon
möglich sein wird natürlich das Darling
Netzwerk damit werden noch mal viel mehr
und viel größere Satelliten möglich die
dann uns super schnell ist und auch
günstiges Internet überall zur Verfügung
stellen mitten in der Wüste kriegt man
jetzt eine mega gute Bandbreite von für
inzwischen 65 € im Monat die Kosten
wurden gerade von gestern noch mal
reduziert auch mega krass und natürlich
das overathing goal das allergrößte
Dinge warum space extra gemacht
sie wollen zum Mars viele Maske möchte
die Menschheit zum Mars bringen dort
eine Kolonie aufbauen und das geht nur
wenn man sehr sehr viel Gewicht darüber
bringt und das wiederum geht nur wenn
dieses Gewicht sehr günstig
rüberzubringen ist zumindest deutlich
günstiger als das aktuell der Fall ist
und dafür ist das Starship der
wichtigste Teil das ist unser Vehikel um
zum Mars zu kommen und auch günstig
viele Menschen zu Maßen bringen und auch
ganz ganz viele Equipments zu nass zu
bringen das ist alles natürlich noch
irgendwo ein Luftschloss und ganz ganz
weit weg aber ich sage euch ganz ehrlich
vor zehn Jahren habe ich das alles auch
schon gehört fand es auch schon
faszinierend und da war es noch viel
viel weiter weg da war die Falke nein
noch nicht wieder am landen 2015 ist die
Felgen zum ersten Mal gelandet und da
habe ich das erstmal gedacht
dem das könnte tatsächlich was werden
und heute erleben wir vielleicht den
nächsten großen Schritt nämlich dass das
Starship tatsächlich fliegt und
funktioniert und wenn es das tut dann
mich tatsächlich sehr sehr optimistisch
dass Elon Musk mit SpaceX irgendwann zum
Mars fliegen wird vielleicht nicht mehr
dieses Jahrzehnt aber ziemlich sicher
nächstes Jahrzehnt aktuell ist ja der
Plan 2029 das wurde auch schon häufig
nach hinten geschoben also lasst uns das
ganze mal abwarten aber
es sieht tatsächlich ziemlich krass aus
ziemlich gut aus und ich bin schon sehr
sehr aufgeregt dafür weil wir erleben
gerade wie Geschichte geschrieben wird
aktuell reden wir alle immer noch über
die Saturn 5 über die Apollo Mission one
step for a small step for men Kind das
ist immer noch ein Satz den wir
regelmäßig sagen und das liegt daran
dass das da was monumentales passiert
ist und ich glaube wir erleben gerade
die ersten Schritte von dem gleichen für
die nächste Generation und dass wir
diesmal dabei sein können wir werden wir
erleben das gerade mit und wer das jetzt
gerade verfolgt der kann das noch seinen
Kindern und Enkelkindern erzählen weil
das ist das sind die ersten Schritte
davon wie wir zu einem anderen Planeten
geflogen sind
noch 26 Minuten ich drücke die Daumen
dass es heute funktioniert ich höre noch
mal rein was SpaceX selber im Stream
gerade sozusagen hat damit ich hier
nichts verpasse weil ich rede gerade
sehr viel wenn ihr Fragen habt schreibt
sie gerne in den Chat oder okay
aporation
33 Raptor 2 Triebwerke das ist
vielleicht so die größte success story
von dem allen diese Triebwerke sind
unglaublich kraftvoll vor allem für das
Gewicht das sie haben und ähm die die
erste
das erste Triebwerk dieser Art das so
funktioniert und ist dafür extrem
beeindruckend und ermöglicht eigentlich
erst das ganze Starship also diese
Raptor Triebwerke die hier seht die sind
wirklich krass wenn heute alle 33
Staaten sind das wäre schon Erfolg dass
alle 33 angehen auch dadurch darf da
werden wir heute sehr stark darauf
gucken ich habe noch ein paar Fragen
bekommen von euch Benni fragt zum
Beispiel wo nimmt SpaceX das Geld für
diese ganzen Raketenstarts her haben sie
schon größere Einnahmen ja auf jeden
Fall die haben
SpaceX macht was für die Nase also die
bringen zum Beispiel Menschen und Cargo
zur ISS das bringt sehr gutes Geld rein
die haben schon die Verträge bekommen
zum Mond zu fliegen mit dem Starship
auch das bringt jetzt schon Geld und die
haben natürlich eigenes Starling
Programm was wo Leute sich jetzt schon
für anmelden können die kriegen dann so
eine Satellitenschüssel und bezahlen
dann monatlich Geld das wird auch mit
der Zeit immer größer man weiß
allerdings nicht was die konkreten
Einnahmen sind denn space X ist privat
man kann keine Aktien kaufen ich will
doch schon gefragt ob ich Aktien kaufen
würde wenn es denn öffentlich wäre
ja würde ich wahrscheinlich weil ich
tatsächlich das ganze ziemlich cool
finde und daran glaube dass das bald
noch viel viel größer wird und das hätte
ich am liebsten schon vor 10 Jahren
gemacht selbst da habe ich schon gedacht
boah geil das ist doch mal was was
richtig richtig Zukunft hat und was
extrem beeindruckend ist damals hätte
ich gerne schon Aktien gekauft
Schnitt ja auch fragt Cedric würdest du
dich zum Mars fliegen lassen wenn es
soweit ist
was heißt denn wenn es soweit ist also
jetzt gerade würde ich das
wahrscheinlich nicht machen ehrlich
gesagt auch also schon gar nicht als
erster weil ich mag die Erde schon sehr
und ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt der
Meinung dass es für uns als also in
unserer Generation keinen Sinn ergibt
den Mars zu besiedeln wir müssen uns
irgendwann machen und ich finde spricht
auch nichts dagegen beides zu machen
aber es ist definitiv eine höhere
Priorität auf gerettet die Erde gerettet
unsere Ökosysteme hier rettet die
Biodiversität halte den Klimawandel auf
viele fragen mich häufig wie passt das
zusammen den machst du wie sie den Kind
sowieso eine Flucht von der Erde ähm wir
werden sehr viel dadurch lernen die ISS
z.B hat so viele Erfindungen
hervorgebracht in ihrer Zeit in ihrem
development und in ihrer aktuellen mit
in ihrem aktuellen Betrieb das ist ja
eigentlich fliegendes Labor es ist ein
Wissenschaftler Labor dass wir davon
sehr sehr viel ziehen und sehr sehr
viele Menschen leben auch schon mit
gerettet haben z.B kann man von also aus
Satelliten generell nicht von der ISS
speziell kann man ähm Waldbrände
beobachten wie die sich ausbreiten oder
man kann zum Beispiel auf der ISS hat
man ganz viel beobachte die Pflanzen in
der Schwerelosigkeit besser wachsen und
daraus konnte man Erkenntnisse ziehen
die uns hier auf der Erde helfen mehr
und bessere Pflanzen zu ziehen die
vielleicht auch klimaresistenter sind
was wir in den nächsten Jahren brauchen
werden um viele Menschen zu ernähren
space travel ist teuer und es sieht aus
wie Milliardäre die hier irgendwelche
großen bumbum Raketen anzünden aber es
hilft tatsächlich uns hier auf der Erde
denn es gibt uns ein großes Ziel für an
dem wir alle arbeiten können und
deswegen bin ich ein großer Fan von der
Weltraumfahrt
so ich wurde auch noch gefragt bis wie
viele Minuten vorher kann der Staat
abgebrochen werden wenige Sekunden
vorher tatsächlich wir haben beim
letzten Mal gesehen 40 Sekunden vor dem
Start wurde alles noch abgebrochen die
Betankung kann jederzeit quasi recycelt
werden
wenn die rettertriebwerke einmal
gezündet haben selbst dann kann man es
theoretisch noch abbrechen wobei ich
damit dann eigentlich ehrlich gesagt
nicht mehr glaube aber selbst das kann
noch passieren also wir können jederzeit
eigentlich noch abbrechen sobald einmal
alles losgelassen wurde die Rakete
fliegt ergibt ein Abbruch natürlich sehr
wenig Sinn und Zweifel wird dann
explodieren
das hatte übrigens Eric Obst gefragt und
F hat gefragt worin besteht der Sinn ein
Raumschiff im Wasser landen zu lassen
anstatt ist auf Privatgelände
explodieren zu lassen und somit nicht
das halbe Meer mit Treibstoff zu
verseuchen gute Frage weiß ich auch
nicht gute Frage würde ich den würde ich
space Ex tatsächlich auch gerne fragen
denn zwei große Dinge so 9 m X 50 bzw 9
m x 69 einfach mehr zu versenken mit dem
ganzen Treibstoff Tonnen tonnenweise
Treibstoff ja wie du schon sagst kann
eigentlich nicht gut sein für die
Atmosphäre für die für die Biosphäre
dort für die Tiere für die Fische ist
nicht nice
und ich kann dir nicht sagen warum es
ist so machen tatsächlich weiß ich nicht
Lukas fragt gibt es neben SpaceX noch
andere private Raumfahrtunternehmen ja
sehr sehr viele sehr sehr viele viele
sind bei weitem nicht so bekannt hier in
Deutschland gibt es zum Beispiel welche
isaerospace die sitzen im Süden von
Deutschland diesen richtig cool sehr
sehr coole Leute es gibt natürlich blue
Origin von Jeff Bezos die das ganze so
ein bisschen nachmachen könnte man
behaupten es gibt Virgin Galactic von
Richard Branson es gibt ach so viele
google einfach mal es gibt ein riesige
Liste auch Wikipedia da gibt's ein paar
die echt spannend sind da gibt's 3D
gedruckte Raketen es gibt welche die
machen so ein Spin und schießen dann
etwas in die Luft lassen dann quasi
genau im richtigen Moment los also eine
ganz anderes Konzept auch mega cool ist
binnenscheißen glaube ich da gibt's echt
coole private Antwort Unternehmen die
man jetzt gerade beobachten könnte
haben wir noch mal eine Livestream rein
bevor ich die ganze Zeit so viel
quatschen was sagt der
Johns above Virus
21 aktuell
eingeschaltet habt herzlich Willkommen
an die 3000 Zuschauer herzlich
willkommen im Stream heute in 20 Minuten
wird hoffentlich dass es Starship zum
ersten Mal starten
sind natürlich keine Menschen an Bord
das ganze ist ein Test um zu gucken ob
die Rakete mit dem Booster unten drunter
so funktioniert wie sich das vorstellen
wenn wir heute keine Explosion sehen
wäre das ein riesiger Erfolg allerdings
sind die Chancen dafür extrem gering
wenn ihr mich fragt wenn wir schon Max
cure erreichen bin ich super happy also
den Punkt wo die größte Kraft auf die
Rakete wird das wird ungefähr 1 Minute
nach dem Start zusammen sein also in
jetzt 19 Minuten ähm darauf sind wir
gerade sehr gespannt ich drück die
Daumen dass wir heute tatsächlich
starten schreibt mir gerne eure Fragen
in die Kommentare und ich versuche alles
zu beantworten z.B auch von hopkind in
die Ferne hat Maske wirklich mit dem
Erfolg zu tun gibt Mast nur den Leuten
die gibt Masken nur den Leuten die die
Ideen haben Geld oder ist er selbst
tiefgründig an dem Projekt beteiligt
ja das kann man natürlich von außen fast
nicht beurteilen also ist auf jeden Fall
so dass elast das nicht alles alleine
gemacht hat wie viel er jetzt an diesem
Erfolg mit zu verdienen hat ist
schwierig zu sagen wenn ihr mich fragt
ehrlich gesagt würde ich behaupten dass
er auf jeden Fall zu viel credibility
bekommt ich weiß unbeliebt das zu sagen
viele elemast Fans ich war früher auch
ein Elon musk-fan mein Respekt und so
ist für diesen Mann leider in den
letzten Zeit einfach immer und immer
weiter gesunken trotzdem verneine ich
nicht was er schon geschafft hat und ich
bin sehr sehr großer Tesla Fan ich fahre
ja auch ein Tesla bin ein riesen space
Ex Fan ich bin kein großer Twitter Fan
muss ich sagen aber was ich so in den
letzten Jahren gemerkt habe ist das ähm
da sind tausende Menschen tausende super
smarte Ingenieurinnen und Ingenieure die
für Tesla oder SpaceX arbeiten die super
genial sind die ihnen Maske in die
richtige Richtung wahrscheinlich
angeführt hat und auch ursprünglich mal
2007 2002 als erstes gegründet hat die
richtige Idee hat aber wo er jetzt
heutzutage halt einfach nur noch so viel
machen kann wie halt eine Person er hat
halt sechs oder sieben Unternehmen der
splittet seine Zeit zwischen diesen
ganzen Sachen er wird für viele dieser
Ideen nicht hauptverantwortlich sein
dass Design von den Teslas übernimmt zum
Beispiel der Franz von Holzhausen heißt
er glaube ich und die CEO von Space
Access screenshotwell also macht das auf
jeden Fall nicht alleine man kann
eigentlich inzwischen sagen es ist so
ein riesen Team es ist natürlich ein
Gesamt erfahrt und eigentlich sollte man
auch eher den Ingenieurinnen und
Ingenieuren danken trotzdem muss man
natürlich auch sagen ursprünglich Geld
in dieses ganze Projekt getan 2002
nämlich das was er von seinem Verkauf an
PayPal bekommen hat dann hat er die
richtige Richtung vorgegeben er hatte
die Idee mit der Usability soweit ich
weiß glaube ich also er hat schon auf
jeden Fall viel angestoßen und viel in
die richtige Richtung gegeben dennoch
ist er definitiv nicht der einzige dem
heute wenn das alles so funktioniert Lob
gebührt und ich persönlich bin der
Meinung je größer das Team wird desto
mehr ist dann eigentlich natürlich das
Team auch damit verantwortlich wir hier
bei dr Watson sind inzwischen auch das
Team und jedes Mal wenn Video rauskommt
bin ich dafür weniger verantwortlich
sondern wir als Team sind dafür
verantwortlich es gibt inzwischen
mehrere Menschen wir haben eine
Wissenschaftsredaktion die dafür
recherchieren und die sich das Ganze die
das ganze Thema vorher verstehen und
sich durchlesen und dann ins Skript
schreiben wir haben mehrere Leute in der
Postproduktion die das ganze Video
schneiden ich habe viele Leute die mir
dabei helfen das Ganze zu organisieren
das alles zeitlich passt und oft stehe
ich dann quasi nur noch vor der Kamera
trotzdem hatte ich ja ursprünglich die
Idee mit dr whats und habe die ersten
Jahre auch alles alleine gemacht also
wie viel gebührt dann einem das ist
glaube ich sehr schwierig zu sagen vor
allem von außen wo wir natürlich gar
nicht wissen wie viel elast macht man
weiß ja schon dass er sehr viel arbeitet
und auch teilweise in der Fabrik
übernachtet bei Tesla hatte das z.B
gemacht am Start vom Model 3 sich also
extrem aufopfert trotzdem kann ein
Mensch alleine natürlich nicht
unglaublich viel machen
so haben wir noch
einen Livestream
oder ist der Space gerade abgebrochen
bei mir ich sehe auf jeden Fall gerade
nichts mehr
gezeigt habe also wenn ihr das jetzt mal
wieder das ist auch das wissen wir schon
hat nicht funktioniert bin ich bewusst
hätte dass SpaceX das alles zeigt dann
hätte ich euch ja nicht vorher schon
gesagt
wenn das gerade doppelt ist dann können
wir ja noch mal diese Grafik zeigen
Pascal also hier in dem die hinter der
Kamera mit dem wo alles schwarz ist wo
man quasi die große die große die großen
Stadt sieht wo man auch sieht wo nämlich
die beiden sich trennen die beiden
Stufen
da sieht man gleich wenn wir es zeigen
nee die schwarze Grafik da wo die weiße
Linien drauf ist wenn du die haben
könnten
da kann man dann gleich auf jeden Fall
gut sehen was alles
passieren wird gleich zu erwarten haben
finden wir gerade nicht kein Problem wir
sind ja hier spontane flexibel machen
was anderes
jemand hat noch gefragt nämlich white
key wie finanziert ihr euch wir machen
Youtube Videos und in diesem
YouTube-Videos seht ihr manchmal Werbung
drin diese Werbung wird dann von den
Sponsoren bezahlt und deswegen sind wir
da immer genau das das machen wir wir
machen Youtube Videos die von euch
geguckt werden und ähm machen dann
Werbung da drin und sind euch natürlich
auch immer dankbar wenn ihr dann z.B den
Link in der Beschreibung benutzt und
durch dann das Produkt darüber kauft
ansonsten gibt's natürlich noch unsere
Patrons die uns netterweise auch
finanziell einfach unterstützen dafür
ein paar Videos früher bekommen jede
Woche vor allen anderen sich das
angucken können oder mit ähm z.B
schreiben können
patchwork.com erwachsen
und wir machen noch ein paar andere
Sachen also Produktionsfirma machen z.B
Kommunikation für die Max Dankeschön und
arbeiten auch mit anderen Kunden
zusammen wo wir einfach für die
Wissenschaftskommunikation machen also
dann für die Videos machen wo wir
komplexe Themen erklären
eure Fragen an also ich sehe alle eure
Fragen sind sehr viele Fragen zu mir
unglaublich leid wenn ich Eure Frage
gerade nicht beantworte ihr könnt mir
trotzdem weiterhin eure Fragen in den
Chat packen ich versuche alles zu
beantworten
freut mich sehr auf jeden Fall Dominik
Anderson für das tolle Lob danke schön
[Musik]
den nach den Livestream könnt ihr euch
auch nachher anschauen genau und wir
haben auch schon ein Video produziert
dass ihr euch dann hoffentlich nach dem
Start angucken könnt in der Stadt ist
schon in 12 Minuten 50 also langsam
werde ich ein bisschen hibbelig denn
heute wird glaube ich Geschichte
geschrieben wenn alles gut geht werden
wir gleich sehen wie das starstück zum
ersten Mal startet und dann hoffentlich
einen großen Bogen um die Erde macht
[Musik]
gleich geht's los ich kann noch ein
bisschen was über den Hitzeschild
erzählen der ist auch ziemlich krass
wenn das Starship weil sie der obere
Teil wieder in die Atmosphäre rein Berli
flott also mit dem Bauch zuerst
reinfällt dann wird ganz ganz viel Hitze
entstehen nämlich die Luft wird so stark
zusammengepresst es liegt nicht wirklich
an der Reibung sondern daran dass sie
zusammengepresst wird dass sie anfängt
zu brennen und zu Plasma würde entsteht
unglaublich viel Hitze und das was wir
jetzt gerade sehen können diese schwarze
Unterseite die soll jetzt dann dafür
sorgen dass diese Hitze abgeleitet und
absorbiert wird das ist Keramik auf der
Basis von ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben
Siliziumoxid und das ist so Design dass
das mehrfach direkt hintereinander
wieder funktionieren kann dass das
Starship soll dann also der obere Teil
der schwarze Teil den jetzt gerade sehen
soll quasi auch von diesen Greifarm
aufgefangen werden und wenige Stunden
nach dieser Landung direkt wieder ready
sein das heißt dieser Hitzeschild soll
mehrfach verwendet werden können was
unglaublich krass ist und wenn das so
funktioniert dann wäre das ein sehr
krasses Material viele Expertinnen und
Experten aus der Branche sind sich da
aber noch nicht so ganz einig ob es das
jetzt schon ist da muss wohl noch viel
passieren also das heißt wenn heute
alles gut geht spätestens bei den belly
Flop am Ende würde ich eigentlich
erwarten dass dieses Starship
auseinander gerissen wird einfach weil
dann die Hitze und die Energie zu groß
wird die darauf wirkt und weil der
Hitzeschild diese ganzen kleinen
Hexagons eigentlich noch nicht so bereit
sind die sind da muss noch einiges
passieren
ingenieurstechnisch und Design technisch
vielleicht werden wir gleich eins der
lautesten Geräusche miterleben dass
jemals aufgenommen wurde denn SpaceX hat
als eine weniger oder fast als einziger
kein richtiges Wassersystem
normalerweise wird ja ganz ganz viel
Wasser auf diese auf den unteren Teil
der Rakete drauf geworfen oder oder so
quasi unten auf den Launch man unter die
Rakete und zwar vor allem um die
schallwellenabzug abzuhalten die auch
z.B reflektieren könnten und die Rakete
dann wieder stören könnten das passiert
nicht bzw es gibt nur so ein Sprinkler
System aber es deutlich weniger Wasser
plus es gibt halt 33 Triebwerke die
beide die alle jeweils 230 Tonnen Schub
machen das heißt es wird unglaublich
laut und ich bin schon sehr gespannt das
gleich zu hören es wird nämlich
wahrscheinlich sehr sehr beeindruckend
zu hören und es könnte auf jeden Fall
auch ein Weltrekord brechen
der launchtower den ihr sehen könnt ist
er noch mal ein bisschen größer als die
Rakete selber nämlich 142 Meter hoch und
ihr seht diese arme die sollen
theoretisch dazu in der Lage sein dieses
sowohl den Booster als auch das Starship
wieder auffangen zu können wenn das
ganze dann senkrecht wieder sich quasi
davor bewegt und landet dann gibt's noch
ein paar tolle Animationen zu dass es
extrem beeindruckend wirkt aber auch
super krass also ich kann mir das gar
nicht vorstellen das kann ja so viel
schief gehen auf der anderen Seite hat
SpaceX auch bewiesen mit der Felge nein
die können sehr präzise landen die
können immer wieder landen das
funktioniert eine einzelne Rakete ist da
glaube ich zehnmal wieder gestartet und
wieder gelandet und wieder gestartet
also real Usability funktioniert
tatsächlich SpaceX hat das gehalten was
sie versprochen haben deswegen habe ich
auch tatsächlich relativ viel Vertrauen
generell in space x auch in heute und
diesen Staat das dass das in richtige
Richtung geht die Design Philosophie
stimmt schnell sich bewegen schnell viel
kaputt machen und dann daraus lernen
nicht alles durch bürokratisieren so wie
zum Beispiel die NASA oder auch die ESA
könnte man behaupten
das sorgt glaube ich dafür dass sehr
sehr viel sehr schnell passiert und
elemaske will ja auch schnell zum Mars
möchte das alles noch in seiner Lebzeit
irgendwie auf den Weg bringen wir
befinden uns übrigens gerade hier in
Texas Boca Chica da ist die Star Base
und man sieht hier sind sehr sehr viele
Menschen die sich das angucken wollen
ich glaube das ist auch ein krasses
Gefühl dazu stehen man würde
wahrscheinlich dann sehr sehr viel von
diesen Schallwellen abbekommen und ich
werde natürlich auch sehr gerne jetzt
gerade vor Ort aber das konnte ich mir
leider nicht leisten jetzt nach Texas zu
fliegen für so einen Start deswegen muss
ich mir das leider hier aus Köln
angucken von wo guckt ihr denn gerade zu
schreibt mir das doch gerne mal in den
Chat liebe Grüße an alle die jetzt
gerade im Stream sind an alle 4000 von
euch sind schon krass und in 8 Minuten
geht's los ich bin schon sehr aufgeregt
Danke schön an
white Key für den Support
und wir hören mal wieder den Stream rein
denn ich laber glaube ich sehr viel und
wir hören sehr wenig vom Stream aber wir
wollen natürlich gleich gerade bei dem
Start sehr viel vor allem vom Stream
hören damit ich alles mitbekommt Leipzig
Bonn Leipzig wie ein Schweizer Zürich
Osnabrück Hannover Schweiz Heidelberg
viele Schweizer
ich bin übrigens auch Schweizer Pass fun
fact was die wenigsten wissen ähm wohne
aber in Köln
glaube nicht dass du vom Arzt kommst
Rostock Grevenbroich
Schau von Texas
warum dampft das wegen des flüssigen
Methans methan ist bei -160 Grad sofort
am Kochen und sobald das in die
Atmosphäre geht wird es fängt sofort an
zu kochen und wird zu diesem coolen
coolen scifi-mäßigen Dampf den wir hier
sehen
[Musik]
Ägypten Neumünster Flensburg ja Grüße
schön dass Sie alle Zukunft ich bin
schon äh freue mich gerade sehr und bin
sehr aufgeregt let's go hoffentlich
sehen wir gleich eine Rakete die größte
und leistungsstärkste Rakete aller
Zeiten werden wir hoffentlich gleich
starten sehen
mini mini Einwand dazu die N1 Rakete ist
tatsächlich die bisher schwerste Rakete
gewesen und hätte noch mehr Schub die
ist allerdings nicht in den Orbit
bekommen das heißt wenn wir gleich ein
Orbit sehen ab dann ist quasi die größte
Einsatz also einsatzfähig sowieso aber
natürlich nicht die größte jemals
gebaute Rakete aber meine Rakete die da
nicht fliegt aber gebaut wurde zählt die
wirklich
keine Ahnung also das da schon
riesig es ist wirklich wo wir gerade
drauf gucken ist ein Hochhaus ihr müsst
euch das wirklich vorstellen wie hoch
aus 9 Meter Durchmesser und 120 Meter
Höhe es ist unglaublich beeindruckend
und es wird noch größer 130 Meter soll
es mal werden ob der Booster dann noch
69 Meter hoch ist das wird sich zeigen
dann ist der Joke auf jeden Fall kaputt
aber wenn wir heute starten happy 420
ja
aufgeschrieben
und dem Sauerstoff der auch ausgestattet
wird quasi ausgestoßen wird und dann
zwei Sekunden später wird dann der
Launch das ganze entzünden das ist jetzt
glaube ich gerade meine Vermutung dass
wir 8 Sekunden bei 10 - 8 anfangen sie
werden riesige weiße Wolke zu sehen und
danach dann zwei Sekunden später bei 6
Sekunden vor dem Start werden wir dann
auch Feuer sehen
ist gut es wird eine Explosion sein das
ist eine quasi eine kleine Atombombe die
da steht das sind knapp 5000 Tonnen
Treibstoff den wir da haben
1200 im Starship alleine 3400 im Booster
das sind also
4.600 Tonnen Treibstoff das ist eine
Bombe die da ist ein riesige Bombe dazu
die gleich angezündet wird es ist
unglaublich krass
[Applaus]
ja Grüße nach Wien zurück an Maxi
Taschen für danke für dein Support sehr
nice 5,99 €. danke schön
übrigens nicht finanziert also die
machen einfach auch Spaß finde wir haben
heute keine Werbung kein Sponsor kann
gar nichts machen wir einfach sowas geil
ist und auch das Video heute dass wir
behandelt vorproduziert wird auch keine
Werbung drauf geben machen wir also kein
rechnerisch Verlust mit für die Firma
aber ist einfach so geil heute ist
einfach so krass das muss ich miterleben
und ich dachte wenn ich schon sowieso
gucke dann kann es auch mit euch
zusammen gucken mit
4700 von euch krass Leute
für die 2 €
diese gehen raus
wann sollte das Raumschiff in die Kippe
gehen bzw wie lange dauert dieser ganze
Stadt versucht da können wir gerne noch
mal einblenden dann das letzte Mal wir
zeigen natürlich jetzt ab jetzt gleich
den Stream aber noch mal ganz kurz
eingeblendet was werden wir gleich sehen
was wird uns gleich erwarten 8 Sekunden
vorher startet auf jeden Fall getan und
Sauerstoff genau
startet die Rakete bei einer Minute nach
dem Start sehen
hammergeil bei ungefähr zwei bis drei
Minuten nach dem Start wird werden erst
die Booster ausgeschaltet und danach
werden sich die beiden trennen dann ist
das Starship getrennt von dem Booster
der Booster fliegt zurück nach Boca
Chico und wird dann im Golf von Mexiko
senkrecht über dem Wasser kurz havan und
dann einfach ins Wasser versenkt werden
und das Starship soll dann einmal um die
Erde fliegen und nördlich von Hawaii
belly floppen also mit dem Bauch zuerst
einfach ins Wasser platschen dass wir
das alles so sehen werden ist ziemlich
unwahrscheinliche werden gleich irgendwo
in meinen Augen was explodieren sehen
ich hoffe natürlich dass das nicht so
ist aber ich wollte eure Erwartungen
gleich schon mal managen in zwei Minuten
und 40 Sekunden geht es los und ich bin
schon sehr aufgeregt ähm geht mal auf
den letzten Productions ab was werden
wir gleich sehen werden wir maxq
erreichen werden wir alles schaffen
werden wir überhaupt starten wird wieder
irgendwas abgebrochen aktuell sieht
alles gut aus Wetter ist noch gut
wir sehen blauen Himmel weiter oben so
ein bisschen mehr Wind geben aber
anscheinend entscheiden die sich einfach
da trotzdem durchzufügen wird
zwei Minuten noch
und mein Puls geht nach oben
sieht alles gut aus
hey leute
das wird die Raumfahrt verändern
ein historischer Tag
[Applaus]
werden die Geschichte miterleben
wahrscheinlich wollte
hey wir haben die 40 Sekunden Marke
überschritten das ist sehr gut beim
letzten Mal nicht geschafft jetzt noch
30 Sekunden bis das Starship die größte
und leistungsfähigste Rakete aller
Zeiten startet und hoffentlich abhebt
drückt mir die Daumen oh wir sind wieder
gesprungen
okay spannend
30 Sekunden wieder
Countdown wurde weggenommen
das heißt wir gehen wahrscheinlich
wieder irgendwo rein
Information okay
so kurz davor das ist wirklich
nervenaufreibend und wirklich aufregend
also es kann sehr gut sein dass es
weitergeht gleich aber irgendwas scheint
nicht optimal zu sein das heißt wir
haben gerade erstmal den Countdown
angehalten und wir warten jetzt auf
weitere Informationen von der
Flugleitung
ist noch alles gut entspannt euch
Countdown hold for final Lounge
Checkouts
okay
gehen wir mal auf Twitter mal gucken ob
da noch mehr sehen ob schon geklappt
wurde da findet man das meistens als
erstes raus
sehe ich jetzt auf die Schnelle noch
nichts ich würde weiterhin sagen dass
wir gleich vielleicht mit etwas Glück
doch starten können aber fingerscross
knock on Woods willst natürlich nicht
jinxen warten wir mal ab was wir hier
gleich für Informationen bekommen werden
denn aktuell ist nicht klar was die
Sache ist
jetzt aufs Klo gehen ist auf jeden Fall
mutig es kann jederzeit wieder bei 40
Sekunden oder sowas einsteigen
der Praktikant hat den Hauptschalter
vergessen ja Klassiker
Leute es ist noch nicht vorbei es ist
noch lange nicht vorbei es kann sehr gut
weitergehen das ist einfach nur ein
kurzer Stopp wir werden vielleicht
gleich hoffentlich starten die größte
und schwerste Rakete aller Zeiten
eine der hässlichsten Raketen überhaupt
weiß ich nicht muss ich sagen finde ich
nicht
finde ziemlich schick
aber es ist ja noch nicht die finale
Rakete aussehen soll also es wird sich
vielleicht auch noch was dran ändern
historischer Moment für die Menschheit
sagt Knie sehe ich auch so
diese Spannung sagt ja
couple working
stationär sein soll wir warten dann noch
ab das ist auch schon mal passiert kein
Problem
120m soll aber bald sogar 30 Meter
werden diese Version ist gerade 120
Meter und damit die größte Rakete die
wir gebaut wurde
jemand fragt wohin die fliegt an das
Tasche oben drauf liegt einmal um die
Erdball herum und landet dann wieder
nördlich von Hawaii starte den Texas
einmal komplett um die Erde rum
innerhalb von 70 Minuten der Booster
soll wieder da landen wo er startet aber
halt im Wasser soll er wieder landen
senkrecht über dem Wasserhahn und dann
einfach ins Wasser versenkt werden
Prototypen kann man nicht sagen
allerdings möchte SpaceX mit dieser
Rakete die Kosten revolutionieren und
auf unter 10 Millionen oder ungefähr 10
Millionen pro starten was revolutionär
wenig wäre
an den eisberger eisberger Eis
der gerade ein bisschen ich habe die
Frage beantwortet
7.300 Zuschauer herzlich willkommen
schön dass Ihr da seid ihr lebt mit mir
Geschichte das ist unser Saturn 5 Moment
jetzt wenn diese Rakete funktioniert
wird es danach nie wieder Raumfahrt
geben wie sie bisher war Kosten werden
revolutioniert die Menge die man bringen
kann die die die 150 Tonnen revolutionär
wenn diese Rakete funktioniert wird das
alles verändern und dann stehen noch
alle Zeichen auf Go dass wir zum Maß
gehen und dass wir wieder zum Mond
fliegen und jetzt sind 30 Sekunden die
Rakete soll gleich schlafen das
funktioniert wieder alles 20 Sekunden
noch Leute
drücken wir die Daumen dass wir gleich
einen wunderschönen Start werden ich bin
jetzt gleich ruhig noch 15 Sekunden wir
hören rein let's go Tasche
[Applaus]
ein
Staat
sehr langsam aus ich weiß nicht sollte
russische
yeah also gleich der wichtigste Punkt 20
Sekunden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mehrere mich angegangen wenn ich das
gerade richtig gesehen habe
schon ähm Manager Tatort dann werden wir
gleich sehen und danach werden sich der
Booster und die Rakete trennen wenn
genug Geld gegeben wurde also wenn genug
geschwindigkeitsveränderung gegeben
wurde wenn der Booster genug
separation
[Musik]
[Applaus]
krass krass krass
und jetzt müssen wir gleich sehen wie
die beiden sich trennen
zwei drei vier fünf gestartet
das aber an für sich erstmal kein
Problem
die sollte sich eigentlich jetzt trennen
im gedreht die sich die ganze Zeit
[Musik]
shift
das habe ich mir gedacht so soll das
nicht sein sind beide haben sich nicht
getrennt und drehen sich gerade
unkontrolliert
großes Boom
das ist kein fail ja das war gerade
total okay das Pad ist nicht zerstört
worden wir haben maxq überlebt
separation hat nicht funktioniert okay
egal das war ein Test und das sollte
also wir wollten heute Daten sammeln das
war okay und das war auch damit erwartet
dass heute nicht alles funktioniert
Booster und Starship haben sich nicht
getrennt beide sind nicht mehr gelandet
aber Leute Starship funktioniert das was
ich Ingenieure da gedacht haben
funktioniert wir werden jetzt in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten
wahrscheinlich mehr von diesen Test
sehen und das ist super super aufregend
das heißt nämlich grundsätzlich könnte
es Starship genau das machen was space
Ex verspricht nämlich die Raumfahrt sie
revolutionieren da ist viele Musk sitzt
ganz vorne und hat tatsächlich geschafft
am 420 die Rakete zu starten
große große Explosion ja FM Chat aber
Leute das war kein kein großes Fehler
sondern tatsächlich eigentlich ziemlich
cool was heute gesehen haben war kein
voller success natürlich hätte es besser
laufen können aber ich muss endlich ganz
ehrlich sagen das war schon sehr sehr
beeindruckend und super aufregend auch
was wir da gerade gesehen haben
wenn das bedeutet die Kräfte die auf die
Rakete wirken wurden ausgehalten bei
einer Minute nach dem Start haben wir
gehört das waren die größten Kräfte die
darauf wirken und das wurde ausgehalten
das heißt die Rakete wie sie designt
wurde mit dem Edelstahl mit den neuen
Metern Durchmesser und so wie sie sich
gedacht wurde hat erstmal den größten
Widerstand beim Start geschafft es gibt
noch unglaublich viele Probleme zu lösen
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll
Hitzeschild ist auf jeden Fall einer
davon aber auch noch ganz ganz viele
andere Sachen
die würden jetzt noch offensichtlich zum
Beispiel die Separation davon hat er
gerade nicht funktioniert das
anscheinend irgendwas schief gelaufen
aber heute wurden zum Beispiel Daten
gesammelt und vor allem hat man gesehen
es gibt eine Rakete Starship an und für
sich als Basis als Plattform
funktioniert und das bedeutet wir können
bald zum Mond wahrscheinlich hoffentlich
die Nase hatten neue Rakete die viel
viel viel günstiger sein wird als das
SLS das SLS ist hiermit eigentlich mehr
oder weniger Geschichte und zwar ist
eigentlich schon als es bevor es
überhaupt gebaut wurde und der Mars
rückt immer näher und das ist
unglaublich aufregend wir erleben gerade
etwas mit was historisch ist und wo wir
vielleicht unseren Kindern noch von
erzählen werden denn die Raumfahrt wird
gerade
günstiger und das ist super wichtig denn
wir wollen ja viel viel viel Gewicht in
den Orbit bringen für vielleicht neue
Raumstation wenn die ISS wenn die ISS
die Internationale Raumstation die
Arbeit wird und aufgegeben wird in den
nächsten Jahren das wird irgendwann
passieren wir brauchen ganz viel um auf
den Mond zu kommen wir wollen ja
vielleicht eine Mondbasis aufbauen und
wir brauchen für alle extrem viel Masse
die wir Richtung Mars schicken und dafür
brauchen wir das Starship dafür brauchen
wir diese Rakete die wir jetzt gerade
gesehen haben
und dieser Test gibt mir gerade
Zuversicht dass das tatsächlich
funktioniert ich hatte ja schon gesagt
ich bin sowieso sehr hoffnungsvoll was
SpaceX angeht weil die Designphilosophie
stimmt die wissen wie man nämlich
tatsächlich mit Raketen arbeitet es kann
es kündigen schiefgehen es werden Dinge
explodieren und daraus lernt man dann
dann baut man schnell den nächsten
Prototypen verbessert war es und failt
wieder failing forward failing fast das
ist die Design Philosophie von SpaceX
und die ist ziemlich Smart wenn ihr mich
fragt also danke an Euch alle danke an
die Mods im Chat dass ihr dabei wart
danke an euch fürs zuschauen danke an
eure Unterstützung wenn ich das dir
gefallen hat dann gibt gerne ein Like
lasst gerne einen like da denn wir haben
das jetzt gerade einfach so aus Spaß
gemacht ich war gerade einfach super
super aufgeregt und hatte richtig Spaß
dran Thomas quanta Film sagt nach der
ganzen Spannung erstmal eine meiner
entspannten naturdokus können
ähm ja warum nicht wenn du gute Nacht
ansonsten wenn ihr noch Fragen habt
könnt ihr mir gerne reinstellen ich bin
gerade ein bisschen aufgeregt und muss
erstmal runterkommen aber denke dass wir
hier bestimmt noch ein zwei Fragen
beantworten können wenn ihr welche habt
schreibt sie also gerne rein viele viele
Rückmeldung viele viele Spenden von euch
danke schön auch an Vokale Tenno und an
Thomas quanta habe ich ja gerade schon
gesagt
was passiert denn jetzt mit den Trümmern
der Rakete fragt zum Beispiel Felix tja
die werden wahrscheinlich einfach in den
Golf von Mexiko gerade fallen oder sind
gerade schon reingefallen und werden
dann da von vom Wasser einfach
verschluckt und die landen jetzt auf dem
Boden auf dem Erdboden auf dem Grund dem
Meeresgrund
und werden dann da ja wahrscheinlich für
die Umwelt nicht so mega geil sein aber
es ist halt auch nur ein ganz ganz
kleiner Teil was bei der Umwelt immer
wichtig ist ist halt die die Quantität
die Menge wir fliegen halt jeden Tag mit
was weiß ich wie viel 100.000 Flugzeugen
die eine Rakete die vielleicht im
Durchschnitt einem einmal am Tag oder
sowas weltweit startet macht nicht den
riesen Unterschied was z.B CO2 Methan
und generell unser Klima angeht trotzdem
sollte man natürlich extrem aufpassen da
eigentlich die beste Firma denn die
wollen ja ihre Raketen wieder verwenden
klar das funktioniert nicht immer und
jetzt gerade bei dem Prototypen schon
gar nicht aber an für sich ist Base Ex
sogar die sauberste Firma wenn man so
will weil die halt alles wieder
verwenden wollen dass da schon ist
komplett real beide Teile sowohl der
Booster als auch das selber sondern
komplett wieder verwendet werden können
und das ist ja Recycling und sehr grün
klar methan ist nicht nice ähm aber es
gibt auch viele viele Nachteile z.B von
Wasserstoff Raketen das hat man beim SLS
gesehen wasserstoff ist sehr schwierig
damit zu arbeiten extrem kleines Atom
kleiner geht's nicht das fällt überall
fließt über wieder raus ganz ganz
schwierig deswegen hat man sich dazu
entschieden mit Methan zu arbeiten das
kann man auch auf dem Mars herstellen
und ja das sind so die Entscheidungen
die da getroffen werden aber wie gesagt
ein Starship und selbst 100 starships
die dann am Tag starten machen noch
nicht den großen Unterschied der große
Unterschied sind die 100.000 Flugzeuge
jeden Tag oder die was weiß ich wie
vielen Autos die es auf der Welt gibt
trotzdem super wichtiges Thema Umwelt
stimme ich euch 100%ig zu ich glaube
aber im Großen und Ganzen dass die
Raumfahrt eigentlich mehr für die Umwelt
tut als sie dagegen tut da gibt's ganz
andere die wir eigentlich da kritisieren
sollten ganz oft die Kritik da glaube
ich bei den falschen und nicht bei denen
die halt logischerweise immer kritisiert
werden sollten weil die werden ja die
werden halt tatsächlich das Gefühl und
oft sind diejenigen die sowieso schon
coolen scheiß machen die dann auch noch
ein bisschen perfekter sein müssen und
ja egal anderes Thema aber das zum Thema
Umwelt von SpaceX wie umweltschädlich
war der Staat hatte auch Nils gefragt
wird SpaceX versuchen den Booster und
das Starship zu bergen nein Alpha Noob
da wird nichts mehr geborgen das ist
jetzt gerade in Einzelteile Rapid worden
also sehr schnell auseinander gebaut
worden ungeplant ist ja immer so der Job
das ist deren Wort für Explosion und
Rapid an Skoda Samy und da wird glaube
ich nichts mehr geborgen selbst wenn
alles so nach Plan gelaufen wäre dass
sie wieder vertikal über dem Wasser
landen und dann ins Wasser versenkt
werden will SpaceX wollte space extra
eigentlich nichts Bergen wahrscheinlich
zu teuer keine Ahnung
wie sicher ist eigentlich der zweite
Flug von so einem Ding ist die Abnutzung
nicht zu hoch und den nächsten Flug
sicher zu machen fragt Hopkins das weiß
man natürlich nicht das weiß man erst im
Nachhinein nachdem man die Daten hat
allerdings kann man ja relativ klar
sehen wie es mit der Fake hinein
aussieht nämlich extrem gut da sind
einzelne Felge nein Booster und Raketen
nicht Booster perfekt in ein Raketen
schon ganz oft wieder geflogen ich
glaube mindestens zehnmal immer wieder
dieselbe ich gehe also stark davon aus
dass sie dieses ability Ding sehr sehr
genau durchdenken und die starships eher
so Flugzeuge sehen nämlich die Fliegen
von A nach B dann werden die noch mal
kurz gecheckt dann guck mal kurz drüber
betankt noch mal neu und dann fliegen
die nach wenigen Stunden direkt wieder
das ist die große Revolution dass das
Ganze wiederverwendbar ist und viel viel
günstiger dadurch wird
wie viel CO2 wird beim Start freigesetzt
fragt Nils i auch kann ich tatsächlich
nicht sagen wir haben mal ein Video dazu
gemacht über grüne Raketen das kann ich
Dir sehr gerne ans Herz legen das
findest du auf unserem YouTube Kanal
wenn du bei dr Watson eingibst
nachhaltige Raketen grüne Raketen
findest du dein ganzes Video zu wo wir
das besprochen haben und wo wir schon
bei Videos sind die wir gemacht haben
wir haben letztens ein Video gemacht wo
wir darüber gesprochen haben wie eine
Stadt auf dem Mars einmal aussehen wird
heute haben wir gesehen die Schritte
dafür werden gemacht dass Starship
funktioniert in der Theorie wir werden
also bald hoffentlich irgendwann im
nächsten 10 20 Jahren Richtung Mars
fliegen und dort dann vielleicht doch
erste Menschen auf dem Mars landen wir
haben Chat gefragt eine künstliche
Intelligenz wie eine Stadt auf dem Mars
aussehen würde und das Video dazu könnt
ihr euch jetzt angucken wir schauen mal
rein los geht's
versorgenden Stadt in der
äquatorialregion des Planeten Mars new
Terror wurde von einer multinationalen
Koalition aus Regierungen und privaten
Organisationen errichtet und ist ein
leuchtendes Beispiel dafür was die
Menschheit erreichen kann wenn sie auf
ein gemeinsames Ziel hinarbeitet
im Herzen der Stadt befindet sich ein
Netz unterirdischer Lebensräume und
Gewächshäuser die den Bewohnern ein
komfortables und nachhaltiges Wohnumfeld
bieten und die sie vor kosmischer
Strahlung schützen modernste
Energiesysteme versorgen die Stadt
darunter Solarzellen sind Turbinen und
Kernreaktoren
fortschrittliche Transportsysteme und
Technologien erleichtern den Transport
von Menschen und Gütern über die riesige
maßoberfläche aufgrund der geringen
Schwerkraft und der niedrigeren
Produktionskosten haben viele
internationale Unternehmen
Produktionsstätten auf dem Mars
errichtet die von der Herstellung von
Konsumgütern bis zur Entwicklung von
Hightech Geräten reichen
darüber hinaus bietet die einzigartige
Umgebung des Mars ein Zentrum für
Forschung und Entwicklung im Bereichen
wie Technologie Planetenforschung und
Astrobiologie mehrere
Forschungsinstitute und Universitäten
haben Niederlassungen in der Stadt
errichtet und wenn es ums Feiern geht
weiß new Terra wie man es richtig macht
der marsianische Unabhängigkeitstag ist
eine besonders aufregende Zeit nicht nur
aufgrund der Schwerkraft trotzenden
bounce races die sich die geringere
Schwerkraft des Planeten zu Nutze machen
ein einzigartiges marsianisches Erlebnis
dass man nicht verpassen sollte
gerade gesehen habt war eine künstliche
Intelligenz oder mehrere künstliche
Intelligenzen tatsächlich und zwar haben
wir zuerst shetschi PT gefragt wie eine
Stadt auf dem Mars aussehen würde und
dann haben wir die ganzen Proms davon in
mit journey gepackt und dadurch Bilder
generieren lassen der ganze Prozess ist
noch mal deutlich komplizierter und wir
haben danach auch noch gefragt wie eine
Stadt auf der Venus aussehen würde und
wie ein Generationen Raumschiff aussehen
würde mit dem wir zu anderen
Sternensystemen fliegen dieser ganze
kurze bis fünfeinhalb Minuten lang und
danach gibt's noch eine Erklärung wie
wir das genau gemacht haben das haben
wir jetzt am Sonntag hochgeladen und wir
haben auch gerade schon in den Chat den
Link dazu gepackt guck da gerne mal
drauf bzw jetzt auch in der
Videobeschreibung könnt euch das Video
angucken da sind wir sehr stolz drauf
dann zeigt so ein bisschen wie krass
künstliche Intelligenz eigentlich jetzt
schon ist und was man damit auch
Positives machen kann und es zeigt so
ein bisschen wie wir auf dem Mars leben
können ich finde es auch merken mega
krass dass die KI gesagt hat dass man so
im Boden drin ist und sich zum Beispiel
vor der Strahlung zu schützen das war
voll die smarte Idee ich meine klar
waren auch schon ein paar Menschen drauf
sind doch schon ein paar Menschen drauf
gekommen aber es ist trotzdem krass das
künstliche Intelligenz sowas weiß
wir haben heute gesehen wie Geschichte
geschrieben wurde es war ein krasser
krasser Test ja es gab eine Rapid an
scheduled disassembly also eine
Explosion eine sehr große Explosion
sogar aber wir haben extrem viel gelernt
und das Launchpad wurde nicht zerstört
und wir haben maxq überlebt deswegen
würde ich sagen war das heute ein voller
Erfolg wir haben heute gesehen wie das
Starship zum ersten Mal so richtig
geflogen ist und das ist unglaublich
beeindruckend unglaubliche zeiting ich
freue mich schon sehr auf die nächsten
Monat und Jahre wir sind gerade dabei zu
sehen wie ein neues Raumschiff das
größte und leistungsstärkste Raumschiff
aller Zeiten entsteht und bald unser
Leben verändern wird wir werden damit
zum Mond fliegen wir werden damit
vielleicht sogar zum Mars fliegen wir
werden damit Satelliten Internet
revolutionieren und das alles
mitzuerleben jetzt gerade ist
unglaublich aufregend
danke euch fürs zuschauen schaut gerne
unsere anderen Videos rein und jetzt
bald kommt auch noch ein Video zum
Starship dass wir schon vorbereitet
haben das sollte heute abend online
gehen also abonniert gerne dr Watson und
das nicht zu verpassen und wie immer an
euch vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und
bleibt neugierig